what's going on everyone Spencer here
and today we're bringing you some Ghost
Recon wildlands gameplay the open world
landscape definitely pulls me in and so
far I've been enjoying this game if
you're a longtime fan of the Ghost Recon
series what was your first Ghost Recon
game let us know in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this video feel free
to like share and subscribe for a lot
more [ __ ] he's just an obstacle now
Hernando's the one we want
copy that narcho with a damn minigun at
the entrance to the camp that's a kill
[Music]
engaging hostiles
ready
Oh what is this who the [ __ ] are you
where's Reed OOP I got no idea what that
is
don't [ __ ] me Hernando you either
tell me where I can find Reed or I make
sure El sueño knows all about your
little human trafficking ring I don't
know where Reed is [ __ ] who never shows
his face unless he's got a shipment to
make or there's some kind of emergency I
think this qualifies as emergency don't
you there's a special I enter it into a
laptop appears trip Reed gets a signal
it comes to the airfield that's it give
me the code
then tell me where I can find this
airfield Roman got to get it our
brothers
helicopter in bed Chuck is running off
that truck has shift needed it don't
blow it is beautiful
don't give the truck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or dismissed
take it a shot
[Music]
[Music]
escaping